if you go and see your family physician  is he required in some manner to  offer you ssris or is he allowed to say  you know maybe you should look at your  relationship that isn't working  or the fact that you don't have a job or  you know whatever else is going on  problem is that it's too  easy to just write a prescription and  they often don't even talk about okay  well how long are you going to take this  there are no long-term trials so we  don't know  what the benefits and harms are over the  long  term my guess is that the harms outweigh  the benefits for most of the drugs that  are given long term for psychiatric  illness  evidence is so weak it could be simply a  placebo effect  that has allowed these drugs to get on  the market so it's a just a crazy  situation